citizens of the reject Nation we are back to
continue Black Mirror season 6 episode 2 log
Henry Greg how are you feeling sir I'm doing
great John I see there's a Scottish town in
here that's right we're gonna do this for the
entire radio so leave a like for bad Scottish
accents and also while you're at it subscribe hit
that notification yours was good yours is the best
and you know what else is the best is when you
guys check out that bat verse t-shirt over in the
shopzeroedition.com store it is the Crown Jewel
of the t-shirts that you have designed I would
say sir and also what's awesome is when you guys
come over to the patreon.com the real reject sync
up with your own copy of Black Mirror and enjoy
The Full Experience everything that doesn't make
the Highlight Reel sync up with your own copy it's
a lot of fun over there got a bunch of other shows
and movies we cover as well and without further
Ado let's jump into the look get in my Bella
[Music] I was worried it's almost six I took a
detour after last to show Pierre the pretty way I
slept through it an American nice to meet you you
too Janet pretty we think you've captured mum whoa
whoa that's racist do you grow up in America or
are you originally Jesus mum U.S born and bred
you are prying mom with these General getting to
know you questions we'll probably set off Monday
morning you're only staying two nights we've got
to head on to run to shoot uh my film a film oh
here we go so that's what your documentary is
about this egg collector from drums he's not a
collector he's guards Red X against collectors
who want to steal them it's a it's a big trade
that sounds awesome this is going to be a story
about one of the last remaining holdouts against
the commodification of nature wow voter man
who watches eggs also that does that thing work
nice no tape boo what are you gonna film with it
I didn't know we were watching the idol good
to go what's Burger rack uh old detective show
your folks were seriously into it they love cops
mum had a crush on John Nails she used to say I
had a nice bum I do not want to think about
your mom getting over some did spot well he
did have a nice one yes he did I told you never
show your face in here again hello Stuart hey
well I guess you're gonna
tell me your pronouns oh God
he was on my film course as well oh
he thinks so good he name after him
someday Oh I thought they were gonna name it
after me so yes well that would be the smart
movie diversity and all that oh geez oh God
killing it my man you're still in business
I keep telling Dad if things don't pick up
we just have to bite the bullet and jack it
hey Sean Hannah is he depressed of course he's
depressed there used to be three pubs around
here and that'll be the last man standing it's a
proper Dead Zone because of world culture that's
right it's because of pronouns Ian Adair was the
guy he lived up at five Acres Farm on the hill
there with his mom and dad now people said
he was quiet easily LED not too bright all
of that no but really he was just some local guy
he turned out he tortured and killed people wow
I've got your storytelling Instinct you tell it
what ended with your dad can I
just start from the beginning
then in 1997 this couple in their 20s had a
cottage for their honeymoon I call me still
had tourists like how this feels like a
dramatic reenactment Unsolved Mysteries
they were here for about a week loads of people
saw them the cleaner comes to get their Cottage
ready for the next booking their cars parked
outside and all this stuff's still there no
after a day or two becomes a big story
tabloids pick it up places swarming with
journalists it's a frenzy is this the small
town Scottish murder from the last episode
in here he's had way more than usual
he's making a nuisance of himself ah
there's a poster of the missing couple on
the wall he even makes comments about the
girl and your dad yeah he tells you in his
bath says he's got half a million to come
back and shoot the place up yep and he's
got a shotgun dad asks Kenneth going to
check in on Ian you don't have a one person
so then Dad says yeah of course it's my dad
on the door Ian doesn't answer dad's walking back
to his car when Ian opens the upstairs window whoa
he shot your dad yeah not fatally in
the shoulder bad though oh [__] I was
wondering about that yeah about the illness
thing yeah backup went from inside the house
you know dare to show his mum
and dad total wiper pharmacy
now that should be your documentary
inside it's like a torture room [Music] oh
no I'd been abducting people keeping them
down there and doing God knows what's
in them for weeks at a time with Mom
and Dad right upstairs the honeymoon
couple and the rest of them the rest
pale horses how many are we talking about
eight all been tortured and the rest of
them dark six things really extreme stuff but
you're dead he his injuries weren't that bad
he was in hospital for a couple of weeks right
but while he was in there he got MRSA and that
killed him over time oh so he did die for
a minute can we go see where it happened
whatever the technology element comes where's
that old camcorder we can do some of that can
we get in there no cause why would you want to
get in there because this is what our film should
be about exactly yeah bring the Taurus back we
can pitch to production companies who will fund
it I had a meeting with cases are at historic I
think she might go for that people already know
the story I didn't I mean it's not who done it
there's no mystery that doesn't matter dude the Mr
awful it is irresistible sounds tacky no no
no no no no no we won't let it be you're being
insensitive to your boyfriend's background you
just got here you don't want to make it I will
yeah he died now you want it glorify him so much
[__] for Mom she lost her husband okay okay and
we can make that point her point that would sell
even more really open up the trauma with the whole
family this is my mom's curiosity box I call it a
morbidly obsessive collection man he looks creepy
whoa four days since Dawn and Simon chalice
were last seen alive in the tourist hot spot of
Loch Henry the holiday Cottage they'd rented left
eerily abandoned I feel so real yeah this was real
the local area still no sign of the missing couple
that all seems quite odd and thus Stewart's dad
especially because she's hot I hope she's
okay I guess she was with us who cares
I love that we're watching a a montage about
editing yeah that's the horror yes someone spent
so much time combing coverage to make this Montage
uh can we just go back to the part where you
getting attention
this season feels so better yeah dangerous
of making a true crime documentary on Netflix
from stream Berry I can see you're very
busy that's that's Stuart Church boy
she's had no idea this whole time yes we're doing
a documentary about what happened you'll explain
what he did to your father only if you want us to
I want you to people should know retribution yeah
if he and Adair was still alive I'd ring his neck
myself with these hands I would get the camera out
save this energy if there's
anything you want me to help with
yeah yes yes yes what an interesting
juxtaposition between the other dad and her yeah
been years since I was in front of any kind of
camera at all last time would have been that
old one year dad had but your dad never had he
wasn't a professional in a day I mean I'd heard
of him but he's not as well known as a Ted Bundy
or a Fred West if we take this anywhere oh for
Network whatever is going to ask is what's the
hook calendar years on stream Berry too his dad
was one of the victims he was a policeman he was
shot at the farm so he was murdered he died later
of his injuries come on make it sound like it can
you get hold of any new material diaries that kind
of thing what about the house itself the dungeon
it's still there and you have access to that yes
so are all the episodes this season from stream
Perry so kind of like I guess maybe I mean like
more meta it also encompassed previous
episodes so maybe they're just all yeah
I'll get a light up is that your stage
blood mix that is still in the bag this
is lemon juice oh what's that for shows
up on the black light like piss and uh
just drip a wee bit down here oh like a day
of jazz 12s letting someone's throat foreign
[Music]
there's a way to incorporate the Eggman
in this documentary though that that you
can sell to the top the hook if you've never
been on a death dungeon before no I find it
quite relaxing I might be a tourist draw in
itself actually exactly people would go make
it an Airbnb he'll take your pants behind your
back slow down no slow down look at the road
it's not a plausible King oh no
yeah come on guys killing it you're lately
still concussed so we have to keep you in
for observation be on the safe side she
knows her stuff look at her she's a doctor
broke Stewart You're the lucky one
though no wanking for me for a month
at least you can throw that cutting
around and tug yourself into a coma
yeah yeah I guess so you rest up I know
right I care he's the only one who's really
it's gotten the worst of this whole experience
seem to eat here sleep so fast thank you
what's about to happen do you have a prediction I
feel like it'll have something to do with telling
the main guy's dad's story but then the other
guy's dad is going to be something like horrible
they don't want to get out or something like
that like maybe he was involved or something or
Mr Kane I really haven't a clue
where any of this is going nope
you have to stop your film why who's the mom
really is she the girl no that wouldn't make
any sense mom's the killer I think I've always
known noon what is she gonna poison her maybe
maybe the mom recorded stuff herself on
these cameras sure yeah yeah I bet oh no
this is so scary what is happening yeah oh
she was involved no no no oh I just got
like severe nipples just ah oh this is
so bad oh no of course she wanted to
tell the story she he was in [Music]
wisdom the mistress he's
gonna have fun with the both
of them she said it's been a while
since I've been in front of a camera
oh wow oh the dad was just trying to protect
it sounds like he still did kill her though wow
wow [Music]
shepherd's pie it's ready I'll plate up climb
out of window you can't drive back at this hour
The Mask that's right I saw the mask
on the wall earlier yeah oh boy okay
fun together seems like that man got
just so Disturbed that he probably
eventually was like I just got a kill yeah
we just need any way out into the bathroom
no signal I wouldn't try to call
I wouldn't try to call just act like everything's
normal a little walk clear my head are you sure
everything's all right I'm fine really oh
I won't be a minute no no no no no no no no
it's a better go back upstairs than
outside maybe the crash gave you a
shot it'll catch cold out here you're fine
you should get in no get in the car whoa
oh man I would have gone upstairs
you seem like you were fine just hiding there
God you need that evidence though like
oh this is so dangerous
oh this is so bad it's just like
they said at the beginning take a
wrong turn get swept off down a
river she doesn't even have the
tape on her damn it it's so frustrating
because yeah she can wipe everything
mementos
[Laughter]
no no
yeah that's more than eight
I think she's confessing
oh yeah she's ending it wow
oh
man your film's gonna be so big it's gonna be huge
there's your piano cue yeah good catch at the
beginning dude the Taurus hotspot of lock Henry
and so he was in front of any
kind of camera at all wow [Music]
local officer Kenneth McArdle and his wife Janet
Ricardo's shot the adair's dead deliberately
wounding himself to cover up his role in the
slaughter sure wow killed herself after leaving
recordings of the murders where her son would
find them what a gift sweet oh geez but your dad
never had all this stuff he wasn't filming
for broadcast no he wasn't can you imagine
truth will out and so to honor this year's
documentaries please welcome Kirsty the 4K
screens yep look Henry will out [Applause]
thriving tourist tree project Junipero
and the bafta goes to lock Henry oh
this is the Black Mirror I know yep
them Awards oh poor guy how awful I am Worthy
star historic ugh shun him out
the red [Music]
cup all the masks ugh
wow
cursive thing
Wowie
this is what happens when you want
to become a filmmaker [Laughter]
can't do anything for the story terrible
things all around Wowie oh that was a thick boy
that was awesome that was pretty good that was
awesome that was the Black Mirror I sort of
missed yeah it wasn't like super technologically
heavy like but there's still a commentary about
our obsession with True Crime and uncovering
the secrets that was fun yeah that was fun
especially with um like Netflix it was so this
is the most like Netflix aware season yeah so
far two episodes in is like it's like literally
Netflix is holding a Black Mirror to itself yeah
so really it's really interesting what they're
doing here um seriously to be tethered by the
streamberry element and now I'm like are all these
gonna be from stream Berry because that's neat it
is and also stream Berry is different from Netflix
in this universe which adds a layer of strangeness
but they've got the check dumb but but it's the
same but they name check Netflix in this episode
which which just further like it is but it's
also like calling attention to its artifice it's
so strange and I mean see what you're saying
Steward name checked it yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and two I mean yeah this is one of
those things where I'm like geez I mean
uh how many of your producers on some of your
own true crime shows have said things like
these and put people in Davis mcardle's position
I mean not that I guess you know you have quite
an extreme set of circumstances but still yeah I
mean this this definitely had that like you know
gut twisting sort of punch that I associate with
Black Mirror like I like the first episode and
it certainly had that like Edge to it but it is
like a bouncy or happier sort of resolve whereas
this yeah is like the spiral opens up and then
it just goes steadily down into the abyss from
there it was like a wound this Davis guy did not
want to open and then sure enough has he climbed
further down into that hole and like that I love
the tragic irony at the end of everything happened
that you would expect to happen the tourists
came in the glorification of The Masks as well
um people want an experience through crime stuff
and like maybe go to the house and all that this
documentary becoming huge but at what costs yeah
you know your entire soul and and what's left of
your your whole life like yeah it's great he
was eight when this all happened so it's like
his whole life has now been outed and and turned
inside out and then to pose that question what's
the hook I think because it's Black Mirror you
trust that there's something that's going to
happen right like there's some other thing that's
good because I was enjoying I was really really
enjoying it um from beginning to end I thought
the acting was like supreme Supreme acting here
um from everyone everyone and the amount of
great misleads that they did with the father
and the mother I'm not talking about Kenny
I'm talking about the guy from The Mummy and
The Last of Us opening you know his name you just
you name checked him the second he showed up John
oh sorry John Hannah yeah yeah sorry
John Hannah he's only in that like
one prologue so I was like wait Last
of Us yeah yeah okay mommy but mommy
well that was the thing is all I could see
in my mind is I was the the main guy and I
was like no wait I don't know his name
but then yeah then I was like oh the
one guy in this episode I recognized
it took me a second to get back to it
whatever so um with John Hannah and the and the
mom because the the flip Roo there where you're
like John Hannah is involved in it in some way
yeah and the mom is a victim in this and then
they have like fascinating choices that happen
where the mom decides to be on camera and her
motive seems to expose to get retribution for
what happened to the dad yeah and it makes sense
why she would feel that way yeah it's really
really smart it's really clever because what
they did give us was a story about like it did
it on so many levels about like a a story about
making the True Crime documentary some of the
artifice into making a true crime documentary
um The Depths he will go to and is this worth
making you know yeah especially with you know
a day and age where we love True Crime like
we love it so much and we love dramatizations
of True Crime serial killers and like Netflix
just had Dahmer which was a massive show and
and followed by tons of conversations about how it
portrays the lives of the victims and all sorts of
stuff and I love a lot of their I love a lot of
like Netflix's true crime series I think they're
they're very very engaging needless to say uh but
there is always that icky part of me that's going
I mean a lot of times you can feel in a true crime
documentary like the the purpose of of telling I
mean a lot of times it's just like fun to watch
yeah as a viewer a lot of times I'm just like this
is just fun yeah that's a geek show yeah you want
to see the dirty details and the the horrific you
know things that you couldn't believe otherwise
yeah uh I I thought that the way they handled like
as they did so much in here as a commentary but
they kept it very character driven from beginning
to end in a way that was filled with surprises
and you just kept feeling like there's something
else coming but I don't know what but the just the
Journey of making the film like they they made one
of those it was one of those episodes or like one
of those movies which is like the fun of making a
film at the same time like there was that sense of
wonder to putting together this this documentary
that could be pivotal uh and I so I thought that
was exciting and they sold it so much to the point
where I was like the sweaters look so real like
yeah is this based on a true story that we don't
know about it you know like I I really had to
question it um so on a technical side too I
thought they just really did an excellent job yeah
but yeah and even like the choice with the mom
coming around at the end I thought was uniquely
done you know because she's still she I loved her
performance because as a psychotic of a woman that
she is she also has so much love in her yes she
absolutely loves her son and her family towards
the dad yeah and looked upon uh those Polaroids
with Nostalgia and like oh the good old days I
miss those times and almost as if when she died
it was like I'll be reunited yes there's nothing
left to preserve here there's nothing of my old
life yeah let me descend to hell and be with my
baby and torture and torture forever it's like she
died when he he died yeah like blames is it is a
really is a really my it's a mind Bender of it and
um but yeah like is it's cool yeah I'm just so
more used to Black Mirror being like a more of a
like a crazy technological thingamajig yeah
and it's not really about that but it is a
commentary on our association with media yeah
just a technology part of it you know I've only
really seen one kind of qualifying quote in
regards to this season from Charlie Brooker
and he did kind of Express a wish to expand or
just kind of instead of coming up with like ah
what what is the Black Mirror episode need to have
just kind of redefining what that is and I think
here there is a roundabout technological
quality in the sense of like yes you have
you know the old camcorder and stuff rooting you
to a time and place you have a drone and whatever
but you also have physical media lasting as an
archive in a time where there's so much Newfound
debate about media that doesn't become physical
at all and that can be kind of hyper-controlled
due to digitization and stuff like that and so
even though that's not the point like yeah like
it seems like the the main thing it's trying
to address is still like a societal phenomenon
heavily tied to technology so it it is yeah more
much more roundabout but I do think of all the
topics for Black Mirror to take on if it's gonna
Drift from Tech specifically I think this does
make a lot of sense because two I mean there's so
much True Crime that centers around that idea of
like oh it was you know the the happy you know
uh all appearances you know very you know kind
of above board couple you know just sort of your
quaint little couple that had this really Grim
dark secret and so I I like the way it juxtaposed
starting it out with this uh Ian Adair figure
and the more you hear about him you're just
like oh yeah of course this guy is deranged
and capable of all this stuff and uh and
yeah like there's there's something about
you know the the ethics of making these true
crime documentaries is obviously on display
in this episode and uh and there are times
where I would imagine that these Endeavors
have gotten it wrong and perhaps incriminated
the wrong people or bolstered the stories of
you know people who were secretly involved
and managed to conceal that or whatever
um so yeah I thought this spun an interesting
picture because it is partly about them being
exploitative but also like them being exploitative
and pursuing this project does ultimately uncover
this greater truth and then that kind of took me
out of the time and place and and more toward the
now moment where like this guy is a cop and
she is you know like a well-meaning lady who
lives in the country these are the kinds
of people that you just assume are going
to be well adjusted or you would assume would
never be involved in something like that and I
think now especially you know we're finding
that uh you know a lot of the people on the
higher rungs of the societal ladder and who do
appear very you know just sort of again above
board quaint and Etc might be actually pretty
depraved underneath yeah it's interesting yeah
so many influencers you sure that's where it
all comes back to so many torture dungeons
but yeah the acting was great too I can't get the
acting like the acting was really sold me it felt
like I was watching a Scottish film yeah everybody
was really just like so natural and like great at
listening and and two like even though we were
sitting there yelling like you know go upstairs
or just like play it chill like like every little
turn felt I I could feel the authenticity of each
choice even if I didn't always like agree
with the action or something like that
yeah I mean I don't really know I think it's
easy to be hear and be logical uh but when you're
you're stranded in a you're in a very you're
so isolated and you're trapped in this person's
home and you know the roads are dangerous and
even though there was dialogue about that they
demonstrated that with the car crash what finally
makes it real yeah you know so it is they do
establish dangerous to me on the road and I was
like I don't blame her for not thinking straight
yeah you know of course I'd be like yeah grab the
tape get out of there hide wait till morning uh
what or just play cool yeah but you also don't
know like maybe she's trapping me here and she's
going to kill me tonight you know yeah when you
you said the thing about the poison I was like
I don't know maybe yeah I could see it happening
and that's great because because then they play
on you and I love the way that the the mom
character ultimately kind of realized like
she she so isn't on that wavelength of she knows
of Pia knows anything at all that it really takes
until they're out in the middle of the road like
it does seem like she really is just concerned
until Pia like Freaks and runs off and then
she's like oh oh yes okay yeah yeah there's
nothing I can do about this well she said that
she would she wouldn't hurt her and I actually
kind of believed her yeah yeah like it's so
and it and it begs this I mean it begs this
fascinating sympathy for a Despicable a character
who has done these horrifically despicable things
gotta be careful about the words here but there
was that interesting moment where there was
a activity in the bedroom that you could hear that
you cut to and you see the mom's reaction to it
and there's parts of this that remind me of
like uh X sure like she's like Pearl in that
movie yeah a little bit yeah you know like
even hearing her son and you think it's like
disproving of this kind of behavior yeah when
really it is yeah like oh I want that again
yeah that's an interesting flip Yeah well yeah and
and two it plays on that small town thing of like
oh well I guess you know yeah sure it's possible
you're isolated you know there's not a heck of a
lot to do already like sure you'll get into some
kind of weird love club or something like that
yeah that's disgusting that was cool yeah that
was really well done really icky and ineffective
I love that one that was a great one yeah that was
great agreed poor Eggman never gonna have a story
told I feel like that episode tops like the last
four yeah yeah I think this is definitely one of
it's fun like in some ways the first episode
appears like it's like that's a black mirror
but this felt like as much as this isn't so much
about like modern tech this felt like the feeling
of Black Mirror I don't know I like these kind of
I mean we've reacted to a movie here called I see
you I just watched missing um I like I love
these kind of like twists and Mysteries yeah
and all that and that are character driven at the
same time yeah these I really love these kind of
uh genres Styles I think they're
really great yeah alrighty well
that's it for Black Mirror episode two um
it's good to have like this this brought
back the feeling of it's good to have Black
Mirror back yeah that brought it back for me
um leave your thoughts down below and this
is the one without any famous people other
than Jonathan Moscow what's his name John Hannah
John Hannah yeah I I thought the woman who played
the mom I think like is in a lot of like High
Caliber dramatic work and stuff like that like
I know I've seen her I can't conjure her name to
mine but uh not that famous I feel like she was
like just nominated for something but yeah
I mean not as not as famous as John Hannah
Salma Hayek and yeah Sir Michael Sarah certainly
not or Blanchette sure or Jesse Pinkman Jesse
I'm just gonna credit him as just
alrighty guys well thanks for
being here let's send this to the
Tyler Hague we all know that we can't
be fooled by your pleasantries you're
full of [__] Tyler hey Tyler you come
across like oh yeah I'm just so [Music]
but you know what's going on on those monitors
you're keeping tabs on your caged victims I know
exactly what you're doing in that moment in time
torture Hague you're just going there and you're
eating their body parts you sick son of a big
gross man and then wearing their skin as hats
but part of me is hoping that that is what
allows you to be you know remaining pledged
is that you're taking their money and shuffling
into your bank account so as long as you just
keep those activities you're doing in Wisconsin
got no issues just don't bring into California
we got enough of them uh but if you just keep it
in Wisconsin your neck of the woods much easier
to get away with it out there no one cares it
keeps things excited so thank you Tyler for not
murdering anyone California um I hope that you
never get caught uh but if our patreon gets shut
down uh no refunds no refunds for to anyone that
you've captured and if you do get caught we get
to react to your story first your footage and
all that stuff all the evidence we get to leak
it and get all those tasty views and then we
you know who could play you in in a dramatized
movie you know who could play Tyler Hague let's
hear it who's you casting who's your fan cast
Jonah Hill Shona Hill he's gonna win that Oscar
finally all he's got to do is go you know to
the real depths of Despair and depravity
everyone needs their one hour photo movie
that's gonna be everyone needs their their
deranged killer movie thanks Tyler [Music]